shadow banking is worth more than 70
trillion dollars across the globe it
isn't just about risky investment
products and lending between individuals
shadow banking also covers loan shark
operations and pawn shops as well as
what are considered more respectable
activities like derivatives and
securities lending what makes them
shadowy is that they operate outside the
regular banking system and that means
it's often not controlled by regulators
the Financial Stability Board says
shadow banking poses systemic risks to
the global financial system the
prevalence of shadow banking makes it
difficult for governments of countries
like China and India to control their
economies through tools like interest
rates or money supply let's take a look
at China where shadow banking looms
largest it's estimated China's shadow
banking sector is worth 6 trillion
dollars about 69% of the economy that's
Vickers saving deposit rates in China
are low and most small businesses can't
get bank loans and so turn to other
sources of lending China tried to rein
in wealth management products last year
resulting in the worst cash crunch in
more than a decade Rosalyn chin
Bloomberg Hong Kong